when you did the movie with Jennifer
Aniston murder yeah you have a make-out
scene with her yes and listen she's a
very nice looking woman she's a great
let your mother can't be your mother
your mother your wife comes with you to
the set yeah
a murder mystery and she's telling you
you gotta make out more with Jennifer
she encouraged to really go in there
because you were probably trying to be
respectful I'm always trying to be
respectful but my tía my wife's first of
all my wife loves Aniston things right
great of course um whenever Jennifer
texts my wife it's great my she smiles
and she looks I so much she just loves
everything Jennifer has to say about
anything and if Jennifer says bye you
know like did you hear this is new
drinking my my wife you got a drink that
drink
she's already drinking it yeah but your
wife gave you tips for kissing Jennifer
ass he said don't ever did she did the
same thing for uncut gems
well uncut gems say there are beautiful
women in uncut gems that you make it
easy Joe you don't see Adam Sandler
[ __ ] a lot in his movies but in uncut
gems and aren't you nude in the trunk of
a car you nude nude moment yes I gladly
I asked a crew member to bring a towel
over quickly that is the most
humiliating part of being nude in the
trunk of a car from a camera crew is
getting out after all my really fully
nude laws covering my with your hand or
I think it was a switch stretcher to the
truck oh yeah oh sorry
like oh I can't imagine oh it's just
horrible that would but I wouldn't have
taken the movie just for that it
certainly made taking the movie a little
more difficult when I read how [ __ ]
naked man I don't